Can you talk about your own specific
experiences slash methods used with
integrating the shadow?
Yeah.
Well I can actually,
I think a tremendous amount of what
you might regard as shadow integration,
which in the parlance of behavioral
psychologists would be something like
assertiveness training,
right?
It's training and how to stand
up for yourself and for your,
let's say for your better self,
which would be the self that you could
use productively over a medium to long
period of time that
would be of use to you,
but also views to people around you.
So it's a self that's owned by the
necessity of taking care of yourself,
but also simultaneously taking
care of the people around you.
MMM.
I think that the simplest way to start
that work is to consult your resentment.
You know,
it's easy to become bitter about life and
to become angry because of course life
is difficult and it's full
of disappointments and
people are also subject to be trail on
the part of themselves and on the part of
people that hypothetically care for them.
And so it's easy to get bitter and to
be resentful and resentment is a very
useful emotion even though I
think it's one of the most,
uh,
damaging emotions if it's
not dealt with properly.
So if you're resentful basically
means only one of two things,
it either means you should grow up and
quit whining and get on with your life.
Or it means that you're being subject
to tyrannical forces of one form or
another maybe emanating from you.
Maybe a consequence of
the natural environment,
maybe a consequence of society.
You're being subjected to radical forces
and you're not putting your own best
interests forward.
Like in that broader
sense that I described.
And I don't mean you're selfish,
narrow interests that only serve the
purposes of instantaneous gratification.
I mean your own best interest in terms
of developing your character over the
span of your life.
If you're resentful,
it either means that you're immature
and that you should grow the hell up.
And so you need to figure out
how much of your resentment is,
is,
is that,
and maybe the allied with the desire to
find other things or people to blame.
But the other possible option is
that you have something to say or do,
right?
Because you're in a situation where
you're violating your own internal ethical
standards and you're
being required pressure,
let's say to say things you don't believe
or to do things that you believe to be
wrong and you need to determine,
you need to start to strategize and plan
how can rectify that so that you can
say what you mean.
Like if you're negotiating with
a marital partner for example,
and there are issues in your marriage
that aren't making you happy.
While the first thing is you
have to take note of that,
right?
To see that you're actually unhappy.
Uh,
the second is that you have to be
willing to engage in a certain amount of
conflict because in order to
sort out what's disturbing you,
you're going to have to allay your
concerns out on the table and say,
well look,
this is bothering me.
You don't have to say,
well,
I'm right and you're wrong
and you have to fix this.
You have to say,
well,
I've noticed that this
pattern of interaction or
lack of interactions say in
our relationship is making
me resentful and angry,
and the danger of that,
of course,
as you're going to take it out
on yourself and your partner,
the Dangerous Passion,
passive aggressiveness,
you know,
you're not going to respond to your
partner positively when they do something
good,
if you're resentful about them and
you're not going to respond to yourself
properly,
and so you have to lay
it out on the table,
but sort of in a spirit of ignorance,
humility,
it's like,
look,
I'm frustrated.
I'm feeling this way
about our relationship.
Here's what I think might be going wrong,
maybe on my part and maybe on your part
and here's what I envision as a possible
solution.
That's also really necessary.
If you're going to say
what you have to say,
which is to manifest yourself
properly in the world,
is you can't just complain
about what's wrong.
You have to think,
well,
what would my minimal
preconditions for satisfaction B,
you have to offer that to the
person that you're negotiating with.
And so then you learn to abide by the
truth to the degree that you can do that
and no one does it perfectly,
you know?
But it,
it's very useful because you're not
storing up a whole sequence of memories
about how you were unfairly
treated and abused and betrayed.
Instead,
you're trying to stay on top of it
and to note your unhappiness and
dissatisfaction when it manifests itself
and to accept that that's the case.
And then to analyze that to
see if it's your problem.
Like I said,
with regards to maturity or if it
indicates that there's an injustice in the
manner in which you and the world are
interacting and then to work to set that
right even in small ways.
And so it's,
it's a matter of character,
logical development and that makes you,
that makes you stronger over time.
And partly what you need,
you know,
in order to do that is you
have to really understand,
and we do this,
this is why we built in the
future authoring program.
We built the section where you have
to outline your most dismal future,
right?
What your future would be like if you
let all your bad habits and character,
logical weaknesses have the upper hand.
And the reason we did this
is because you can't be a,
you can't straighten yourself out
merely as a consequence of hope.
Let's say you lay out a vision for the
future and you think about what your life
would be,
what you'd like your life to be like,
and then that makes you hopeful and
it motivates you because it gives you
something worthwhile and
higher order to work for.
Right?
And that's useful.
That's positive emotion working for you
because positive emotion is experienced
in relationship to goals,
but it's not as not as useful as also
being chased by something you're terrified
by.
And if you have a good sense of how you'd
fall apart if you stayed week and just
exactly what kind of hell that would be.
Then when you determined to do something
like to tell the truth and to say what
you think and to not do
things that you hate,
then you're going to be pulled along
by the purpose that your vision has
provided for you,
but also pushed along by your desire
to avoid the worst forms of hell that
you've already outlined
for yourself personally.
And that can also help you be brave
enough to stand up in a situation that we
would require a conflict.
Because if you have something to say and
you have something to negotiate about
with someone,
then there's going to be a certain
amount of conflictual dialogue that
accompanies that right it to lay out a
set of problems and to describe the fact
forthrightly that those
problems characterize a
relationship and then to seek
for solutions is quite stressful in
the short term and it's really easy to
avoid.
And so people avoided all the time and
then they store up grievances across the
span of the relationships and eventually
the grievances mount to the point where
they return in monstrous form
and just eat everything up.
That's where you get divorces or that's
where you explode at your boss and ended
up fired or that's where you,
you know,
you develop high blood pressure over
15 years because he can't stand all the
accumulated,
uh,
Monse all the accumulated monsters in
your closet and then you drink yourself
into oblivion because he
can't stand your life.
That's all,
you know,
very counterproductive.
But it's easy to avoid that necessary
conflict on a moment to moment basis
because it's very stressful to speak
forthrightly about genuine conflicts.
Especially when you're dealing
with important parts of your life,
but otherwise you don't
straighten them out.
And then you have to
carry all that forward.
So you need to be terrified of the
consequences of not speaking your piece.
And that can counterbalance the
terror of actually trying to have a
conversation.
So.